thanks for joining us America it's a
free call anywhere in North America the
phone numbers triple eight eight two
five five two two five natalie is or
Natalia I'm sorry is with me and Sioux
Falls South Dakota hi Natalia how are
you few questions I am trying to get
into this out of debt I guess but I'm
kind of looking into it and I have no
idea where to go from here I know that
you suggest the baby steps and every
dollar budget which I have done or
started to do no my yearly income is
like thirty one thousand and I think my
dad is twenty five to thirty thousand
mm-hmm right now but and I've cut like a
lot of my expenses out like ATM I got
rid of my cable in my internet I think
up the second time job how much are you
making it your extra job um I don't know
because I just recently started that my
are you gonna be doing home I'm more
waitress there okay how many nights a
week
right now they have Nance three okay
cool and what kind of debt is your
twenty five to thirty thousand and debt
I ended up well before I became a
Christian there was a cold little cavity
and whatever um with my boyfriend at the
time but we were kind of living like a
married couple that we purchased a car
together and we purchase like a few
things we opened a credit card together
um so he left but he made sure that he
ran everything up and then I ended up
painting the car over because I couldn't
afford it anymore
hmm so now I have the repo charge on my
credit score
those credit cards how much of this 25
is the repo charge for 15 15 okay is
that what was owed on the car at the
time that they took it I am not too sure
he I gave him the car because he said
that he was going to pay it and he
didn't and then repo'd it yeah okay so
it's got his name on it in your name
both right nope definitely gestures oh
this guy really played you okay and I'm
so sorry and the how old are you 20 I'm
gonna be 27 October 27 okay okay
and so you well there's two numbers on
the repo number number number one the
first number is the the total amount
that was owed on the car do you have any
recollection or any paperwork on the car
any recollection what you paid for the
car when you bought it I brought it for
32,000 okay and how long did you have it
hmm three years okay all right I the
15,000 could be either figure I don't
know what we've got so anyway the the
total that you owe on the code on the
car at the time of repo sometimes they
turn that number in and that is not what
you owe because they sold the car for
some amount on a repo auction and it
that has to be credited to you okay so
let's say that they took the car and you
owed twenty-two thousand on it and they
sold it for seven the difference would
be fifteen and fifteen would be the
actual debt you do owe now okay but if
they if you only owed fifteen on the car
whatever they sold it for would be
reduced that amount would be reduced by
the amount they sell it for does that
make sense yeah okay so we're gonna set
that number to the side a minute what
other debt have you got
the credit cards which I didn't have I
didn't allow them to I didn't take the
amount that they said that I could
charge
I took a thousand how much do you owe on
credit cards total that have your name
on it
I think mm oh not a lot I know are you
behind all those have you paid those no
I just I just started looking in there
they have your name name only on them
uh-huh okay so that's about 17,000
between those two numbers what other
debt do you have medical expenses and
stuff
and then I have some stuff in
collections
like what let me see oh I've got
oh there's actually some bad checks that
were better in there oh and oh the
totaling about probably 300 and then I
have I had to bank we had joint bank
accounts and I had three bank accounts I
closed the one have you got all of our
accounts that he has access to closed
the other two got closed because you got
all of the accounts that he has access
to closed yes okay including the credit
cards right so he's there when they win
Kuk elections they're closed
okay so he's not going to be able to run
up any more problems for you correct
okay okay good so we've stopped the
bleeding and most of this debt is old
bad debt in one way or another that's
bad news but it's also good news because
you're not paying payments on hardly any
of this right now correct correct you
have anything you're paying payments on
today yeah okay good good all right so
you've gotten an extra job you're on
every dollar we're gonna do a written
budget and here's what you're gonna do
you're gonna buy your food which is
eating at home we're not going out to
eat unless you're unless you get free
food
at your restaurant where you work okay
but other than that you don't go out to
eat food shelter clothing transportation
and utilities basics of life is all you
can do and everything else we're going
to use to clean up this mess because the
more money we throw at this mess the
faster the mess goes away and we want
this mr. go away would you agree with
that yeah good okay so that's what
you're going to do and the great news is
you're not afraid of work and the great
news is you are a person who makes
mistakes like we all do but you have
learned your lesson on a bunch of these
hadn't you you are a lot wiser than you
were two years ago and wisdom sometimes
comes from pain kiddo and he did the
same thing for me so I get it hopefully
you won't lose your hair like I did but
it's stresses does that I'll tell you so
stupid stuff we've all done it and you
got a list of it and you got to pay some
stupid tax I paid plenty in my life and
you're gonna be okay I'm gonna walk with
you so what I want you to do now once
you're doing this the first thing I want
you do is I want you to save a thousand
dollars and just in cash in the
underwear drawer is fine nobody knows
it's there but you it's just a little
baby rainy day fund in case something
breaks on your cars I'm like that okay
baby step one as a starter rainy day
fund baby step two is then we're gonna
list all this mess you've got all these
debts and you're not paying payments on
any of them and we're gonna clean up the
little one and then the next little one
in the next little one the good news is
that you're gonna get your checking
account open back up because you're
gonna get rid of these bad checks first
because they're all small right okay
they're little I mean your tips from one
month is gonna clean up all of that your
tips from one week is gonna clean up all
of that probably right yeah and you're
gonna have no bad checks hanging over
you and then you're gonna have no old
medical bills hanging over you and then
you're gonna have no other little
collection hanging over you see like
$5,000 completely rocks your world the
people that are bothering you gets rid
of all of them it gets it down to two or
three things right yep because a whole
bunch of your stuff is mosquito sized it
is not
sighs pterodactyl dinosaur size right
correct the mosquitoes will drive you
crazy but they don't kill you they make
you think you're gonna die but they just
drive you crazy and that's what these
bad checks and all these little $50 $80
$200 $500 crap is driving you nuts
good news is it's making you do
something about it okay once you work
through those then you go back and
you'll be able to settle this this repo
you'll be able to settle it for about 25
cents on the dollar 20 cents on the
dollar and so three or four thousand
dollars is gonna make that repo go away
so you don't have $25,000 in that you
got less than ten by the time you settle
on that repo so hold on I'm gonna give
you a car I'm gonna send you through
Financial Peace University I want to
participate in your healing you call me
if you need more help I will walk with
you I'm right there with you kiddo I got
you you can do this hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]